gardening has become a national pastime
during lockdown for people stuck at home
it's a way to spend time outdoors a
place of peace and beauty to brighten up
the long days that exaggeration I think
it's been a bit of a lifesaver really
how can you not be invigorated and
undertake all your exercise if you're
working outside in all this beauty the
picturesque village of peb worth in
Worcestershire was a finalist in the
Britain in bloom competition this year
until judging was suspended but
undeterred
they've been determined to keep the
village looking lovely during lockdown
there are so many fantastic gardeners in
this village and people who care about
not only their garden but how the whole
village looks you know all the communal
areas recreation ground the church our
debt cetera and they're all willing to
give time effort money to make the whole
community look lovely it's brought the
village together with people of all ages
helping out
eighteen-year-old fred should be sitting
his a-levels instead he's been recruited
by the village volunteers I'll be
wasting away my room if I wasn't here
making an effort it's not just Gardens
that are thriving
but gardeners to a survey by the Royal
Horticultural Society has found more
than 70% of people lucky enough to have
some outdoor space say it's helped with
their mental health during lockdown this
week they should have been preparing for
peb with open garden weekend but like so
many other events it's had to be
cancelled with people finding other ways
to admire each other's hard work we're
sort of sharing photographs and taking
videos of our gardens and sharing one
line with each other supporting each
other still leaving plants outside other
people's houses that you know that kind
of thing we're still communicating which
is really important at a time when it's
easy to feel down gardening has helped
to lift the spirits of everyone here
Becky Johnson Sky News pep worth in
Worcestershire